all right this is a
diamond digger saga level 89
walkthrough tutorial video
it goes along with the guide that we
wrote on this level and it um
there
i'm making it for a uh group one of our
group members was having trouble
finishing the level
even after they read the tips so
i'm just gonna try to give you some more
insight into what those are all about
read the guide first if you haven't
first because it explains
a lot of things that will be helpful as
far as being it so basically what we got
to do is the toys are all on the outside
so we have to charge this booster to get
them in the next room it's really hard
to get to the
it's hard really hard to get to
big matches so what we're going to do is
we're going to charge it up take these
out and then we're going to keep this
door blocked until we can charge it up
some more
so that
we can
actually get the booster charged in the
second room so you want to make sure
that you pick the biggest possible match
pick matches that are going to make
other matches like this one
is 2 4 six eight nine so this won't open
this lock which is good and it'll also
bring all these yellow ones together so
we can make a really big match on the
next one
see that
and now the blue ones are all gonna pull
together after
so now we just have to make sure that we
don't make any more
pink matches because that's going to
open up the door and we can't open up
the door until it's time to
leave
all right so imagine this one isn't
going to bring any more down so we'll go
ahead and go with the biggest match
there
and
what you can see that the pinks are
going to block out pretty much most of
the board so what we're going to do is
we're going to at least be able to make
one really big pink match before we
leave
so
as soon as the color booster is charged
we'll
get rid of those toys
and we have 12 moves left which is good
we want to go out the door with about
eight of them left i would say
so we're going to make as many matches
in this room as we can
before we open the lock
so and we're going to try to make this
pink one as big as possible in the
process
and that's pretty much all we can do but
as you can see this is a is way bigger
than any match we can make in the next
room
and we already have a little bit of
charge here plus what we'll have
several moves left when we get into the
next room
so we're charged about halfway up
we have 10 moves and we have to be
really smart about how we pick our
matches here
because we want to clear out some space
so we can
hopefully get some big matches
i picked that one because i knew this
one would stay intact
neither one of them was that good but as
you can see by matching lower i can
still make that match anyways
and i have a chance of getting a bigger
one in the process
and you really do have to take your time
and think here because
even one diamond difference
is like
can be
important
there's really no luck involved with
this this is actually like getting the
biggest possible match every single time
i mean there's luck on how they fall but
as far as
as far as how you charge the booster
it's by
each individual diamond
so this is the biggest one we can't
really fool around
we have to get
a couple more
with and you also need one match left to
actually activate the booster
but there it is
and now we just
clear it out and complete the level
like i said the plus two booster can be
helpful here i didn't use it but
you know that can make a big difference
and just make sure you count them and
and at least
if you can't charge the booster a lot in
the first room like we did there i mean
that wasn't a very lucky
try as far as things go but you can see
that by
setting up a really large
match
for our final match to open the door in
the first room that we were able to
charge it enough
i hope this helps make sure you
leave a comment if you have any
questions
and
i'll be making more videos if you have
trouble with the level just let me know
thanks